ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Great, hi everyone.
It's great to be here, and
I hope you guys are
having fun so far.
It's great to meet
all of you too.
So this is the day where we talk
about how to randomize.
A few other topics will come
up here and there, and
hopefully you will stop me
whenever you have questions,
and let me know.
So don't hesitate to stop even
if it's just a clarifying
point or a deeper, more
substantive question about
what I'm saying.
The three basic components of
this morning's lecture will be
first about methods of
randomization, and that'll
be-- the majority of what we'll
talk about is going
through a few different ways
that we talk about
randomization when we
talk randomization.
One of the common misperceptions
that I've seen
in the world when I am meeting
with organizations or
governments for the first time,
and they've heard of a
randomized trial as a concept,
they often have a very well
defined and narrowly defined
concept of what that means.
And the fact is, there's a lot
of creative ways that we go
about doing randomized trials
that adapt to different
settings, because there's a lot
of situations in which you
can't do what might be
considered the most standard
prescription drug type
randomized trial.
And so we have to be a little
bit creative in settings and
understanding, what are the
constraints we're facing, and
how can we adapt the methodology
to fit in this
particular setting?
Or maybe not, right?
So that's going to be methods
of randomization, we'll go
through a few of the key
approaches that we use.
The second, and this is
a topic which really--
to say this is topic one, topic
two, topic three isn't
quite exactly right.
And by the time we finish one,
we're going to have talked a
lot about number two and number
three, a lot of the
number two being gathering
support for evaluation.
And the point here is that one
of the reasons why we choose
one method over another when
we're thinking about how to go
about setting up the design is
because some methods are going
to be easier for gathering
support for evaluation, and so
that's part of a back and
forth process with
organizations and situations.
And then we're going to try to
walk through a typical plan,
so to speak.
Perhaps in my mind, one of the
single most important things
to remember about doing an
evaluation is to remember that
we're not trying to just
ask, how did we do?
There's nothing wrong with
asking that, but it's very
short-sighted.
What we should be asking
is, what should we do?
And that's the point of a good
evaluation, is to guide us in
future decisions.
If you're a donor, and you're
running a huge initiative, and
you're spending $20 million
or something--
I'm just picking a number--
and you want to do an
evaluation of this.
But because of whatever the
nature of your program is,
this is it, this is the only
time you're ever going to do
it, and it's a weird program
that you believe in, but it's
weird, and no one else is
ever going to do it.
I realize it's kind of a weird
example, just go with me.
And so that's a situation
in which, I think, most
reasonable people would say,
why are you doing an
evaluation?
What's the point?
Is it just to pat yourself
on the back?
Is that really the goal?
Because if there's not future
money that's at stake, future
money that we have to decide
how are we going to spend,
what's the point of doing all
this, other than just to see
whether I made a good decision
in the past or not?
But that's not really useful,
that's not why we're here.
We're here because we realize
that there are tons of future
decisions being made, and we
need better information in
order to make those decisions.
And we need those as donors,
but we also need those as
organizations.
And that's one of the key things
going back to point
number two in the outline.
How do you get organizations
on board and excited and
involved in evaluation?
It's when the evaluation is
actually able to speak to
questions that they have.
And so good evaluations often
help to identify the key
implementer's questions
and answer them.
And I know I'm making that sound
really simple, like oh,
that's all we have to do.
But the key really is to taking
that type of approach
when working with
organizations.
How do you turn these things
into win win for operations?
If you're a leader in an
organization, and you're not a
researcher, so you kind of
understand the value of
research, and it sounds like a
good thing, but you're hired
because you need to go and
deliver these services, and
you need to be efficient in
delivering your services.
You want to know that the
research is nice and good and
needs to be done, but isn't
going to get in your way.
Or if it is going to get in your
way, you're going to get
something for it.
And that's a very common
attitude, and I can respect
that attitude, if someone is
just really focused on
operations.
And so the question is, how can
we design research, how
can we listen to what the
operations people are saying
about what their challenges are,
what their struggles are,
the choices that they're
making that are tough?
And actually build into the
research ways of helping them
answer those questions.
So that's something that
we often aim to do.
Methods of randomization.
I'm going to walk through four
different methods that we will
often use: basic lottery, a
phase in, a rotation, and
encouragement.
And we'll talk about
each of these.
These are not all mutually
exclusive
methods, to be clear.
So I'm just going to point out
there's different ways and
levers for doing things.
Is that readable?
OK.
Sorry, let me skip that slide,
and we'll come back to it at
the end to recap.
So let's start with the
simplest, which is a lottery.
A lottery is like a clinical
trial, where if we were
running a test for prescription
drugs, it would
be a very standard, regimented
process.
We'd be perhaps in
some hospital.
We'd have some sort of intake
process with people who are in
the hospital and have certain
criteria, and then we'd
approach them and say,
there's a new drug.
It's experimental.
There's risks, there's
potential
rewards, it's up to you.
You have the following disease,
these are the issues
you're facing.
What do you want to do?
But that's a situation
where we would take
1,000 of the people.
They would all get informed
consent being told about what
the risks were.
There would be parameters set
up so that if the outcomes
were proving very decisive
one way or another,
the study would end.
But it's fairly straightforward
from a
statistical standpoint and
from a research design
standpoint.
You bring them in, 1,000 are
entered into the study, 500 of
them are randomly chosen to get
a pill, 500 are randomly
chosen to get a placebo, and
you measure the outcomes,
whatever they may be,
from getting the
pill versus the placebo.
And so the question is, can we
apply this in social science,
outside the laboratory
type setting?
So some of the constraints that
we face when we try to
take that really simplistic
way of doing things.
So the first is that
we often can't--
when you're doing a randomized
trial on a prescription drug,
the whole point is the
research study.
That is what it is.
There is no program
around this.
It's a study to see what
the effectiveness of a
particular pill is.
If we're working with an
organization that is trying to
do teacher training in schools,
trying to issue
loans, trying to promote
savings, trying to teach
agricultural practices,
there's a program
there that's involved.
And you can't just go in and
change things around in the
program without paying attention
to what this
actually means for the goals
of the program has.
So the second really important
element is that it must be
perceived as fair.
Now the thing that's the single
most common situation
that I find myself in is when
I'm dealing with organizations
that are capacity constrained.
They only have enough money
to go to 200 schools.
to make 1,000 loans.
They only have enough marketing
people to visit
5,000 households and promote
savings, or whatever the
activity is they're doing,
there's some capacity
constraint.
And so one principle that I've
actually taught my children,
very young, they all know--
so like last week, we had to
fly, and I hadn't seen them
for the weekend.
So the kids all wanted
to sit next to me.
I have three kids.
And it was resolved
very simply,
no whining, no nothing.
We just randomly chose one.
And they all knew immediately.
Now in fairness, I've
done this before.
But they knew instinctfully just
that this is-- there's no
complaining here.
There's no favoritism.
We took each of their
boarding passes, we
flipped them upside down.
We chose one.
Actually I said it backwards.
It was one that couldn't
sit with me.
It was two with me and one
without, so we chose the one
who didn't.
Now ironically, the two that did
win ended up both falling
asleep immediately, and so I
switched seats in the end.
But that's a different issue.
But the point hopefully is
clear, that there's really, in
some respect, nothing more fair
than a random process.
It is giving everybody who is
eligible, who's aware or not
aware, depending on how the set
up is, but everybody who
is within a setting of--
who has access to a program, and
giving them all the same
chance of participating.
Now in a lot of settings, we
would actually suggest that
this is actually more fair than,
for instance, letting
politics and letting nepotism
and letting any sort of other
favoritism play in to
deciding who gets
things and who doesn't.
Which we all know, in many
places are serious issues for
the allocation of any sort of
resource, that depending on
how it happens, then that could
actually be the worst
possible outcome that we
would want to see as
philanthropists, as utilitarian
individuals
interested first and foremost
in alleviating poverty.
But you could tell other stories
in which there is
processes where you really want
to reach the very poorest
of the poor.
And so you have to--
let's come back to that
issue towards the end.
I'll use that as an example
later in the lecture.
So it must be politically
feasible.
Now, it might not be politically
feasible if people
who have the power in the local
settings are not willing
to do it, because they want to
be able to choose the people
in their networks to provide
the services to them.
So the politically feasible
could be for the exact reason
that we want to do
it randomly.
It also can just be politically
infeasible for
other interpersonal reasons.
The right people who need to be
part of the decision making
process just haven't really
brought into the value of an
evaluation.
And there are situations we face
all the time like that,
where there's nothing
we can do.
There's just someone who is the
decision maker who needs
to be on board with something,
and is simply not on board
with doing a rigorous
evaluation, and perhaps
concerned about the results that
are going to come out of
the project, in terms of is
suspicious of external
evaluators.
They feel like we know what
works and what doesn't, and
they don't want to relax
control to an outsider.
There's also obviously
situations where people just
feel like what do
I have to lose--
I'm sorry, what do
I have to gain?
Where organizations will be of
the ilk that, look, we have
lots of media, lots
of attention
for what we're doing.
Everybody tells us it's
a great idea.
We're executing, we're
implementing.
What do I have to gain from
doing an evaluation.
If we absorbed more money right
now, I wouldn't know how
to spend it.
And there are organizations that
I've interacted with that
are more or less of that ilk.
And so there's clearly
situations like that.
Must be ethical.
So this is something we're
always very concerned about
and cautious about.
And there are many situations
we find ourselves for the
reasons I mentioned above, in
terms of fairness, that the
random process is arguably
the more ethical process.
But they're clearly situations
that someone could put forward
where you could say,
well, wait a
second, that's not good.
That's not right.
So these are issues that one
has to be sensitive to.
I think one of the things that's
most important here is
not necessarily whether
something's-- we might all be
able to analytically agree on
the ethics, but that doesn't
mean that everybody else will
agree and perceive things the
way we perceive them.
And so even if we can
analytically understand that a
random process is fair, if
someone is just bringing a
certain bias to the table in
terms of the way they think
about a random processes, then
this can be a problem.
And again, this is one of
persuasion and personality
more so than logic
and philosophy.
So, why resource constraints are
an evaluators best friend.
I think I've actually now said
most of this, but basically,
most programs have limited
resources.
And so examples of where this
has been done is training
programs for entrepreneurs
or farmers.
School vouchers is perhaps one
of the single most common
examples we've seen this done,
where there's a government
program to provide school
vouchers for private school or
secondary school, or even
college, and they just can't
educate the entire population
of people who want to go to
private school.
And so there's a voucher
program, there's an enrollment
process, you apply.
There's a public lottery
literally done openly through
the newspapers or on TV.
And that type of transparency
is done in order to make it
politically feasible, so
that everybody can see.
If it's not done that way, then
the concerns become about
whether is really truly random,
it was done behind
closed doors.
Was the politician really just
kind of pulling out his
favorite people?
So lotteries become, in the
simplest of case, it's often
the starting point.
If we can pull off a public
lottery in this way, or
private, either way, then it
really does become the
simplest approach.
So when it's possible,
it's nice.
But there are clearly situations
that come up where
this is not going
to be possible.
So there's also flexible ways
of doing the lottery.
So let's go through a few
different scenarios here.
So first of all, there's often a
question about the unit over
which you randomize.
What we mean by this is, if
you're going to do a lottery,
do you do a lottery at
the individual level?
Or do you do a lottery, for
instance, at the village, by
offering an entire village
a package of services?
Or if you're building wells, for
instance, this is actually
a treatment that's really being
done at the village, not
the individual.
There might be some individuals
who live closer to
the well than others further,
but you're really choosing a
village and building wells.
And so the lottery system
is flexible in this way.
The general concept
is the same.
We've done interventions in
Ghana, for instance, where the
randomization was done at the
village level for receiving a
community driven development
type program.
And so different geographic
clusters were all put into a
public lottery, and half of
them randomly chosen to
receive financial resources
in order to help build an
epicenter, and lots of labor
in terms of helping and
guiding and facilitating the
process for building these
quote, epicenters.
So the second point is that
sometimes when we do
lotteries, sometimes it's kind
of a full versus partial.
What we mean by this is whether
it's done all at once
in one kind of public way, or
whether it's done through an
ongoing process.
And depending on how things
are set up, sometimes it's
done one way or the other.
So the school vouchers is an
example where we would do it
all at the very same time.
There's a whole bunch of people
who apply for a school
voucher program.
There's 5,000 applicants,
there's 2,000 school vouchers,
we randomly choose 2,000, they
get the school vouchers.
In a situation that we've done
in South Africa and also the
Philippines, when we build it
into a credit scoring process.
And so every day, there's 10
applications for a loan.
The bank is not going to
issue all the loans.
They take those 10, they
put them in three
piles, yes, no and maybe.
And then what happens is they
take the maybes and they say,
we only want to make
half of these.
And then we randomize which half
of those get credit and
which do not.
And this is something we've done
now a few times in order
to measure the impact
of credit.
From the bank's perspective,
this is exactly one of the
cases I was talking about before
where there's a win win
from an operations standpoint.
This is a bank who says, these
are genuine maybes.
We don't know if we should be
lending to them or not.
We're not sure if
it's profitable
for us, we're a bank.
So this is a method for them
that helps mitigate their
risks in deciding what their
portfolio should
look like as a whole.
And from our perspective,
provides this nice lottery
system where some people are
randomly assigned to get
credit and others not.
So let's go back, and now let's
think about some of the
things that will often happen
when you do a lottery design.
Suppose you have 500
applicants and
you have 500 slots.
At first glance, you might think
you're kind of screwed.
You set up this nice, big
process, and lo and behold, it
turns out you didn't have
over-subscription.
You thought you did.
You thought you were going to
use this over-subscription to
randomize who gets in
and who does not.
So what can you do in this
type of situation?
So there's some low hanging
fruit type answers, and
there's also a possibility
that this wouldn't work.
But the first is, could you
increase the outreach
activities?
That a lot of times in this
situation, what this really
means is that whatever was done
to market this program
was not effective in getting in
the right number of people.
Because the intent was to get
1,000 or 2,000 people
applying, and only
500 applied.
So now think about, from an
operations standpoint, what
does that tell you
about applying?
And that might be one of those
cases where there's actually
useful, interesting research
for the organization.
If the organization was saying,
we're going to get
2,000 people applying for this,
and then only get 500,
well, it tells you that maybe
you could do something to help
them learn how they can get
their marketing up.
And so then you can test out
different approaches for
marketing that helps the
operations learn more about
what is it that brings in people
to apply for these
scholarships, or whatever it is
that's being done, and at
the same time, benefits the
program from increasing--
I'm sorry, benefits the
evaluation from getting a
larger intake.
The risk with this is that you
end up bringing people into
the program who weren't really
part of the target program.
So if that's the answer, then
this is actually a really bad
idea to go out and do more
extensive marketing.
If you have to go through extra
leaps and bounds in
order to bring people in, so
much so that it changes the
nature of what the program is,
that's a situation where you
might want to go back to the
drawing board and think again
about what the right
answer is.
Suppose there's 2,000
applicants, and suppose in the
process of doing this that the
organization that's doing
things says, you know what?
There's 500 worthy candidates
and there's 500 slots.
So a simple lottery
would not work.
So we have some sort of
screening process, and we
ranked them.
And we can rank them, and we
put numbers by everyone.
So why should we do anything
other than just
taking the top 500?
So when that type of thing
happens, a lot of times the
questions that we want to ask
then are about what was the
screening process that
was being used here?
So let's go back to the credit
scoring study that I was
referring to.
The thing that we're struck by
when we've done this credit
scoring is really how wide that
maybe category is, when
you really get into the nuts and
bolts in talking with the
lenders about where their data
are coming from, and the
quality of the data, and how
they're individual judgment
weighs in to influence where
people fall within those three
buckets, the yes, no, maybe.
And the fact is that the
profitability of the person at
the high end of the maybe is
really not much different, if
at all, from the low
end of the maybe.
And so the point is that when
you get inside and figure out,
what is it that's really going
on that made them say, well,
we had 2,000 applicants
and we had 500
eligible, so we're done.
If you got inside the box a
little bit more and talked
with them about how they got
to those 500, things would
start coming out of that process
that might be the
exact areas were you can
say, why is that
necessary as a criteria?
Is that really something you
want to filter on to bring
people in or out?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Let's say your
criteria are, one is gender
and one is educational level
for the purpose here.
And let's say that, for whatever
reason, you can't be
sure that the educational
level is really
what they say it is.
So you could go ahead and
select on the basis of
educational level, knowing
that maybe people are not
telling the truth and
that would be OK.
You could remove that as a
criteria entirely, or you
could find some other
kind of proxy.
That might work, right?
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Kind of random.
PROFESSOR: But that's exactly
kind of one of the key things
that would come out.
So the point is, let's just go
with the middle example.
If you really think that the
education was what you wanted
to screen on, but you don't have
confidence in what you're
looking at as actually being a
reliable measure of education.
But yet that's causing
a filter to draw
you down to the 500.
But then when you get inside
and you realize this is a
really bad measure
of education, why
are we using this?
And then all of the sudden you
relax that one rule and you're
up to 900 people, it tells you
that maybe this isn't such a
good way to be filtering, and
I should be doing the 900.
And while I'm at it, maybe I
should try to think about how
to measure education better
or something.
So let's take another kind of
example, which is-- and this
actually mimics the story I have
up here about training,
but the credit scoring
example is another
example exactly of this.
Where you end up--
and I said that right
here, sorry--
you can think about having two
different piles of people
that, when you say there's 500
that are eligible, really
maybe what you have is not 500
that are eligible, but you had
200 that are really eligible.
You really want them in the
program, they must be there.
And then the next 300, you're a
little more questionable on.
And the next 300 really weren't
so different from the
300 after those.
And so what you can do in that
type of situation is set up a
process where you say look, if
you have certain eligibility
requirements, you're in.
And then you're also not
part of the evaluation.
And it's the next 300 that we're
going to combine with
the following 300 after that,
we're going to put together a
pool of 600, and we're going
to randomize those.
Now this has a clear benefit
and a clear cost.
The benefit is that you can
now get a very nice, clean
estimate on the impact
of those 600.
The cost is we've changed the
research question here.
We've changed the evaluation
question.
We're no longer answering the
question, what is the impact
on everyone who receives
this service?
And that's not a good thing.
We don't want to lead
with methodology and
then force fit questions.
We want to set the research
questions.
We have to ask ourselves, how
much are we losing by only
studying those individuals?
And in some settings, those are
the exact individuals you
want to study.
But in some, maybe that's
not so the case.
So in the credit scoring, I
think of those as the exact
people we want to study.
Because when we think about
programs that expand access to
credit, what we're doing is
we're talking about those
people on the bubble, and we're
talking about ways of
getting them access that they
didn't have otherwise.
And the people who have really,
really good credit
scores and are very credit
worthy, they're not the ones
we're thinking about
when we think about
expanding access to credit.
So let me give you another
example of one where this
would be bad.
So we are doing these programs
about targeting the
ultra-poor, where we
go into countries--
I'm sorry, we do go
into countries,
but we go into villages--
and we first identify the 20
poorest people in the village.
And then of those 20, we hold
a lottery, and 10 receive
services and 10 do not.
And then we do this in
about 30 villages.
And the organizations we're
working with, it's exactly the
setting I'm describing here.
The organizations we're
working with
have a fixed budget.
They can provide services in
each situation to 1,200
people, and that's it.
And if we went into
120 villages, they
can do 10 per village.
If we went into 60 villages,
they could do 20.
But either way they look at it,
they got 1,200 people that
they're going to be able to
provide these services to.
It's going to be an asset
transfer, they're going be on
goats and training and
consumption bundles.
Now, if in some these villages
people said,
well, wait a second.
We have the 20 poorest people
in the village, yes.
But four of these people are
really just standout poor.
They're much, much poorer
than everybody else.
So we want to exclude the four
very, very, very poorest and
make sure that they get it with
certainty, and then only
evaluate the other 16.
So this would actually be a bad
thing from the evaluation
perspective.
It might be the right thing to
do, and we can talk about what
the trade offs are.
We're not actually doing that,
and I'll explain why.
But from an evaluation
perspective, that would be now
changing the research question
in a bad way, as compared to
the credit scoring, where
I was arguing
that it's a good change.
So why?
Well, because this is a problem
where we really do
actually want to know the impact
on those bottom four as
well as the next 16.
And so if we did something where
we just allowed the very
bottom four to get the program
with certainty, and then only
evaluated the next 16, we're
missing an important part of
the sample frame.
Now, the reason why, in these
settings, we've done it as the
full 20 is because
realistically, when we've
actually gone into these
villages and done this type of
exercise, it's difficult, if
not impossible, to get
consensus that there's really
four people that stand out.
And the fact is, even when
you're measuring poverty--
and we do have some objective
things, we all know that
there's lots of components
to poverty.
There's lots of ways
of measuring it.
It's not even just consumption
this month, its vulnerability
in general as a concept, which
could be about the variation
over time, and how vulnerable
you are, and how your social
networks are for helping
you absorb shocks.
There's just many different ways
of measuring it, and it's
unrealistic to think then we
can go into a village and
really draw these amazingly fine
lines to say these people
are standout different
than the rest.
When you're going into a village
of this size and
you're finding the 20 poorest,
those 20 are statistically
indistinguishable from each
other, more or less.
So that's the philosophy
of the organizations.
And that's the reason
for doing it the
way we're doing it.
So sometimes, exclusion
is not desirable.
Sometimes there's no way,
whatever the context is, of
excluding individuals.
So other points that we will
often use is the expansion of
a program, or any sort of
program where there's some
sort of initial stage, and
then what you're doing is
you're simply randomizing where
that initial stage is,
or where the program
expands into.
A program is only going to go to
so many villages, and they
can't exclude, but they can
control where their
individuals, where their credit
officers, where their
program officers, education
trainers, whatever it is that
they're doing, they obviously
can control what villages they
go to and what they do not.
So when there is a process
like this, where there's
gradual expansion, we often
will think about doing a
program evaluation using
a phase in approach.
A phase in approach basically
says, look, we're going to go
to all 1,200 of these villages
over the next three years, but
we can randomize which ones
we go to in each year.
So everybody's going to get
services in the long run.
Now one thing that's nice about
that is, particularly
when there's community led
interventions, there's
oftentimes a desire to have
some involvement from
everybody in the program
at some point
in time in the program.
And this is often something that
organizations do ask for.
So phase in approaches allow
for that more naturally,
because everybody's going
to be receiving a
service at some point.
Similarly, the rotation--
which I'll mention in a second--
is a very similar
twist on the phase in.
Where the rotation, instead of
having it be where you slowly
phase in a process, it's a
process where everybody's
actually receiving a service
at all points in time, and
we're just randomizing
who gets what.
So we'll talk about some
examples in a moment about
when that can work.
So some key advantages is that
everyone gets something
eventually, and this provides
incentives to maintain contact
as well with control villages.
They're not just participating
in surveys, although we do do
a lot of surveys sometimes where
there is no intervention
related, and people are
often more than--
at least in our experience--
more than happy to participate
in this interesting, weird
thing, with these people
coming and asking us all
these questions.
But having said that, there are
situations where you want
that continuous support and
continuous buy in to what
we're doing, and so the
advantage is that it provides
them some incentive to
maintain contact.
Some of the concerns is that it
does complicate estimating
long line effects.
If the goal was to study
something over 10 years, but
everybody got phased in at the
end of three, well, you can't
study the 10 year effects.
You can study the effect of
getting something for two more
years 10 years later, but
that's not nearly as
interesting as asking what the
10 year effect is from getting
a particular service.
So let me give you an example of
a situation where the first
is actually perfectly
interesting.
Take neonatal care.
If you want to study the effect
of neonatal care, doing
a phase in across villages is
perfectly fine, because this
is something that is going
to be affecting infants.
And so when you provide that
neonatal care, and you do this
as a phase in, you're now
studying those children, and
this is perfectly fine.
You can study now the effect
of the neonatal care over a
10, 15 year horizon,
even though it was
phased in to everybody.
Because once it's phased in, the
control area of those kids
are three, four, five years old,
and so it doesn't apply.
So I think the main thing to
talk about in terms of phase
ins that does become an issue
about expectations.
So let me give you the
simplest example.
In the world of credit, this
is usually something that
concerns me a lot when we're
talking about doing studies.
And in fact, I've personally
been involved in studies where
there was a proposal to do a
phased in credit program and
we said no.
We didn't do it, because we were
very concerned about what
happens to a control group
individual who was told,
you're going to get a loan,
but just please wait six
months, or year, or year and a
half, or two years, whatever
the amount is.
Now the longer you have to wait,
the less it's an issue.
But if it's a relatively short
period of time, like a year,
then the question is, well,
what were they going to do
with that money?
And is it something they're
willing to wait a year for?
And if the answer is yes, well
then this is a real problem
for thinking that this is a
valid control group, because
what it says is, we're going to
see a delay in an activity
specifically because of
getting access to
this loan in one year.
So what it says is they did
have other options.
They were a little bit more
expensive perhaps, a little
more costly either in
time or interest.
And they said, you know what?
I don't need to build
that new roof now.
I don't need to buy that new
sewing machine for my
enterprise.
I'll go ahead and just put it
off, and I'll do it in a year.
And what it would do is it would
lead us to overestimate
the impact of getting access
to credit, whereas if they
weren't promised this good
loan in the year, they
would've just borrowed at
a little bit of a higher
interest rate right now.
And they still would have made
the investment in their
business, they just would have
had a higher interest cost
that would cause us to
overestimate the impact of our
program, because
we would only--
the true impact is just really
a savings in interest, not
about access to credit in
a binary sense, but
just about the price.
But yet what we would then find
ourselves measuring is
seeing a treatment group of
people who fix their homes and
bought sewing machines for
their businesses, and a
control that didn't, and we
would think that aha, there
was a real binary constraint
here where people were
actually held back from getting
access to credit.
And this program didn't have
that positive effect.
So a rotation design.
So a rotation design is
basically groups getting
treatment in turns.
Group A gets treatment in the
first period, group B gets
treatment in the second.
The main advantage is it's
perceived as fair and easier
to get accepted.
Everybody's getting something,
we're just randomizing what
you get in a given round.
So we have the same anticipation
issue that we
just mentioned with phase
in as one concern here.
It depends on what the two
treatments are, but if you
really want that other treatment
that other people
are getting, and you're told
you're going to get it in a
year, this could affect
your behavior now
for the same reason.
Also it does have the same long
term problem of the phase
in, in that everybody--
if we're just rotating--
everybody
is getting the treatment.
Now, another twist on rotation
is not rotating just--
call it like a placebo
design, so to speak.
Suppose that you just have two
different treatments doing two
totally different things,
everybody gets something.
And you use one to measure
the impact of the
other and vice versa.
So it's similar to rotation,
except not going full circle.
It just means everybody
gets something.
So in something like that, you
don't have this long term
impact issue, or this issue.
But you do have a problem where
it's not so clear what
you're comparing anymore.
So you'd have to be really
careful and think about what
it is you're trying to do.
We tend to think that a lot of
interventions have indirect
effects in many facets
of our life.
So if you're providing
training about
entrepreneurship to one group,
and another group you're
providing some health service,
and you think, well, this is
great, because what does
entrepreneurship training have
to do with health?
And what does health
have to do with
entrepreneurship training?
So I can provide my health
services over here and measure
the health outcomes for my other
group and compare them.
And the same thing with
business activity.
But it's not too hard to tell
stories where these are going
to interact with each other.
So you're healthier, and this
makes you more able to work,
and your business does better.
Your business does better, this
makes you richer, and you
spend more money on health.
It's not hard to tell stories
across two seemingly unrelated
sectors where you will have that
type of effect on each.
You have to think about
those types of issues.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can a rotation work
well in agriculture?
A given country would have--
so you'd like to give
the farmers--
everybody gets something.
Some people get credit, some
people get seeds, some people
get a variety of things.
But obviously some places have
good soil, some places the
farmers are near a road, and the
data that you need to look
at your sampling design is kind
of tricky, because you
may not know that much about all
the variables that would
impact a farmer's success.
Rotation seems a nice way to--
because there are so many
different treatments that
people can get, that it would
seem pretty tricky to
implement if there were--?
PROFESSOR: So I think, in that
type of setting what you're
describing, we'll come
to one in the end.
But let me just say an example
here, which is the question
you're proposing about
agriculture is about how
different treatments will
interact with other
treatments, and with
underlying context.
So there's two things going
on in your question.
One is how does soil quality
affect whether a certain
treatment is effective or not?
And the second is maybe credit
alone is bad, and maybe seeds
alone is bad, but the two
together is good, and things
of this nature.
So that's not a setting where
we would think instinctively
about a rotation design.
That's a study where we would
think about two things.
One is making sure that our
study is being done in a wide
enough variety of soil, to use
that example, so that we can
actually study the effect on one
soil quality and another.
And then the second thing is we
were thinking about having
multiple treatments, but not in
a rotation style, but in a
way that you have some people,
they get seed.
Some people, they
get training.
Some people, they get
seed plus training.
Some people, they get nothing.
So we'll get to an example like
that hopefully towards
the end, but that's
that design.
A rotation design is really more
about when you're doing
something that realistically
will not have an indirect
effect on the other group.
So the example I'm going to give
you is a rotation study
that was done, the Balsakhi Case
that's done, I think it's
one of the cases in
your reading.
It's what what you do
this morning, right?
So that's a classic rotation
example, because what we're
doing is, some schools got third
grade, and some schools
got fourth grade, and
then they rotate.
And the idea is as long as the
third graders don't affect the
fourth, and the fourth graders
don't affect the third, then
this is good, and every
school got something.
And then we just rotate around
what they're getting.
And that's what we mean more
by rotation design.
The key here is that this is a
great example of where the
rotation design was a useful way
of getting the support of
the schools.
It's going to the schools and
get them to agree to do all
these tests with the children.
And it would have been hard to
just go in and get them to do
tests without being offered some
service along with that.
Now they're willing to accept
that the service only went to
one grade, not both.
They understood it was a phase
in within their school, one
gets it one year, that
other, the next.
But that was the way of
getting the schools to
cooperate was by offering
it through this
type of rotation design.
So next is encouragement
design.
Now encouragement
designs are--
first of all, this is orthogonal
to everything else
I've been saying.
Encouragement design can be done
on top of a phase in, on
top of a rotation, on
top of a lottery.
This is not mutually
exclusive with the
others that I've discussed.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I just had
a question on
the phase in approach.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So suppose you wanted
to roll out packaging
group one, and then you'll roll
out packaging group two.
When you roll out packaging, you
notice that something is
not working that well, and then
you wanted to tweak it a
little bit, you wanted
to change the spec.
And for the sake of the
experiment, are you not
supposed to tweak it when you
roll it out to the second
group, you just keep
it the same?
Because [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So great question.
I think the key here is to
think about the timeline.
I don't really have
a chalkboard.
The key is to remember that with
the phase in-- so let's
go with a really simple
phase in, two waves.
So in that setting, the second
group, when you do the
treatment with them, that's
actually after
the study is over.
So the idea is that they're
really your control group, but
they're participating with you
because they know they're
going to get it in the future,
or whatever the
circumstance is.
So that's a situation in which
the answer is yeah, you can do
whatever you want with them.
But if you did know from
operational observations that
the treatment itself wasn't
working so well, then just
remember that when you're
evaluating something, what
you're evaluating was a program
which you already
think from operational reasons
was less than effective.
And so that should perhaps
inform you a little bit about
things like what to measure in
terms of what you want to put
in the followup surveys.
I suppose we could complicate
your question a little bit and
add a third wave.
So you have three waves,
one for each year.
And after the first year you
learn, oh, turns out we
shouldn't have done
it like this.
We should have done it
differently, and so you want
to change things for
the second wave.
And that's perfectly fine.
It does mean now when you're
doing your analysis, you
should think about this
as two studies.
You have your first wave, and
you can compare that to your
wave three, that is control
for the entire study.
And then you have your second
wave, and you can look at them
for one year and compare them to
wave three, and you really
have two different studies
in that setting.
So encouragement designs, like
I said, this is not mutually
exclusive to the others.
And encouragement design,
just think about
what the word means.
It means we're encouraging
people to do something.
We're not forcing, we're
not mandating.
That means the control group
does not necessarily have
nobody getting services, and
a treatment group does not
necessarily have everybody
getting the service.
There's simply something done
to encourage people to do
something, to participate.
Now the key here is to think
about what we're really
saying, is the control in the
phrase randomized control
trial, the reason for the word
control is this idea that the
researcher has some control over
the process in deciding
who gets a service
and who doesn't.
So now we're just moving the
control, and it's no longer
over who gets the service
and who doesn't.
It's over who's offered the
service and who's not, or who
has some encouragement to
get the service or not.
And we still have perfect
control if it's executed
properly over that offer, over
that suggestion, that
encouragement.
But we don't have perfect
control over who actually gets
the service.
So a very simple example of this
is suppose that I gave
each of you a marketing brochure
to go to Au Bon Pain
during lunch and go because of
their delicious scones, and I
only gave it to half of you.
I am now encouraging half of you
to go, the other half not.
Anybody can go to Au Bon Pain,
I'm not controlling that.
And if I wanted to then, for
some reason, study the effect
of going to Au Bon Pain,
I could do that.
I'm not sure what the point
of that would be.
But the point is, I'm only
controlling who receives this
offer and who doesn't.
I'm not controlling who actually
goes to Au Bon Pain
and who does not.
And so this is often the easiest
thing to control in
the process.
And the entire key here from
a statistical perspective--
not the entire, we'll go into
some other issues-- is about
what that differential usage
rate will be among those who
were encouraged and those
who were not.
And when you get into power
calculations later in this
week, that's going to be a
very important element to
think about.
Because if that encouragement
is really, really weak and
just barely changes people's
behavior, it means you need a
huge sample.
In an extreme, an encouragement
design is
exactly a perfectly controlled
randomized controlled trial.
An encouragement that gets
people who get the marketing,
every single one of you goes
to Au Bon Pain, and if you
didn't receive the marketing,
nobody goes.
Statistically it's
the same now as a
perfect lottery system.
But usually when we're doing
encouragement design is when
we have some expectation for it
not to be perfect, and so
we're using that.
So what makes something
a good encouragement?
So I think there's two
things to think
about that are important.
One is that it's not
itself a treatment.
The minute the encouragement
design itself becomes a
treatment, then we have to think
about what is it that
you're actually evaluating
here.
Your goal is for your
encouragement to be totally
innocuous, to just by chance,
by randomness, some people
will be more likely to use
a service than others.
So you want it to be as
innocuous as possible.
So a good idea is typically
marketing.
We typically think of marketing
as a good approach,
just making people aware of
a service makes them more
likely to use it.
So we've done marketing
experiments, for instance, in
the Philippines a lot where
we're doing some sort of door
to door marketing of
a savings product
offering people savings.
Anybody in the village could
walk into the bank and open a
bank account.
But realistically, only those
who get a knock on their door
become aware enough of
it to actually go and
open up a bank account.
Here's a bad idea.
Let's provide training to people
that encourages them to
use credit.
So let's bring them in, let's
give them a big course about
business management and how to
use credit in order to take
out a loan.
And let's use that as an
encouragement tool for
measuring the effect of credit,
because after doing
this course, they'll be
more likely to borrow.
So the problem with this, if
we want to look at business
outcomes, is we just gave them
a month long course in
management of an enterprise.
And that alone is going to
have an impact on their
enterprise, we think, we hope.
And so if it does, well
then, what are you
measuring the impact on?
Was it an impact of the
training program?
Or was it an impact of getting
access to credit?
And you can't separate
these out at all.
So this first thing to think
about is just making sure that
treatment is really innocuous.
In econometrics, we refer
to this as the exclusion
restriction, in that what it's
saying is that we want to make
sure that the only--
if we're going to draw a link
from the encouragement to the
take up decision to the outcome
measure we care about,
that the only path through
which the encouragement
affects the outcome is as it
generates higher take up.
If it has its own effect outside
of the decision to
take up, now it's a problem
econometrically, and we can't
really claim that we're
measuring the impact of using
the service.
We could only measure the net
effect of the two together.
So the second issue
is for whom are we
estimating the treatment.
So here's my favorite tongue
in cheek example for this.
Suppose we went into a village
and we offered free alcohol to
anybody who takes out a loan.
Might be great in the first
stage in the sense that it
generates lots of higher
borrowing.
But what are we measuring
here in terms
of who we're studying?
We're studying people who
respond to this particular
incentive of free alcohol.
That's certainly not the program
that we're typically
trying to evaluate when we're
trying to do an evaluation of
microcredit.
And we want to make sure that
we're getting the people in
the study who are the right
people, who are the types of
people that are thought about
as the target audience for a
microcredit program.
That means not drunkards.
And so you want to make sure,
you do want whatever that
approach is to be something that
is sensible, that seems
somewhat in the scope
of normal.
Or at least doesn't create a
sample selection bias in the
sense that it doesn't make the
people who take up the program
be particularly different in
a way that is not useful.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So an example that I'm
thinking about is access
or information about a
microcredit program to
participants who are
typically very
uninformed about these things.
So the information
is out there.
Theoretically, it's
really accessible.
But we know that unless we tell
them that this program is
out there for them, chances are
very good that they would
never think of it
on their own.
So that would not then be a good
situation for this kind
of a thing, because we know that
we are in effect offering
them a sort of special in by
the very effect of offering
it, even though theoretically
it's accessible.
PROFESSOR: I would actually
says that's
actually a perfect setting.
To do this, let me rephrase the
question, which is suppose
you have a program, and only the
highly informed normally
are going to come in.
And so in order to do an
encouragement design, what
you're doing is you're going out
and you're only going to
move the people who are
not highly informed.
The highly informed already
know about you.
They're either coming
in or they're not.
You give them information, it
doesn't matter, I already knew
about this.
So what you're doing is you're
moving the less informed
people, you're informing them
about the service you're
offering, and now they're coming
in or not as they wish.
But they're more likely to come
in now than the people
who are not informed.
So this is a perfectly relevant
approach if it's the
case that this is an
organization that does aspire
to grow, and they're going to
grow through informing people.
In most of the settings I've
been involved in, at least the
type of information we're
dealing with is usually not
much different than what
they do normally.
It's just marketing.
It's just targeted and
controlled marketing, where we
control what villages they go
to do the marketing, or what
household's doors
they knock on.
But in a lot of situations,
the encouragement design
literally has them doing exactly
the same operation's
that they normally would do.
But it's just recognizing
that it's
still a voluntary decision.
They can't make someone
borrow.
They're going to a village,
they're holding meetings,
they're presenting what
they do, and some
borrow and some don't.
AUDIENCE: I think I'm saying
something slightly different,
but that might
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
So among the group who would not
normally know about this,
it's not that I'm going to--
I'm not saying the group who
knows, forget about them.
I don't know, I'm confusing
myself.
We're assuming that the group of
people that we work with to
provide our program, we would
provide a precursor program,
and we would say among people
that we work with, half of
them we would tell, and half
of them we won't tell.
Is that what you're
saying too?
PROFESSOR: You would go out
of your way to give them
information about the program.
Everyone can get in, but you go
out of your way to approach
half and tell them about
the services.
AUDIENCE: Understanding that
chances are that if we don't
tell them, they won't go,
because they're just
uninformed?
OK.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I don't want to
interrupt if there was more to
this exchange.
My question is about
distiguishing thing between
marketing and training.
If the treatment is something
like a financial product or
service that's poorly
understood, and you don't want
to-- do you think that maybe
financial literacy is an
important determinant, but you
want to isolate just access to
the product or service and keep
financial liberty separate?
How do you draw the distinction
between marketing
and training?
PROFESSOR: I can tell you in
one setting, here's what we
did to try to understand
this better.
Let me restate the question,
which is how do you
distinguish between marketing
and training?
This is really a spectrum.
So an example I gave that was
bad was a month long training
program, and I said it's fine
to just knock on a door.
Why am I drawing
the line there?
And it's a perfect question,
and I can tell you that the
first time I actually ever did
this type of design, we
actually had an entire treatment
group that was just
knocking on doors, but
with no product.
It was just to test out whether
the knocking on the
door had an effect on savings.
So we had two treatment
groups.
We had a treatment
group that got a
commitment savings account.
A bank officer went to the door,
knocked on it, gave them
a pitch about why they need to
save, and savings is good, and
here's a goal.
You should have a goal
for savings.
And here's an account that we'll
offer you to help you
reach your goal.
It wasn't a very long pitch, but
it was a marketing visit.
And we had a pure control that
got no contact from the bank.
And then we had a second
treatment group that we called
the marketing treatment group.
And this group got the knock
on the door, got the same
pitch for about 5, 10 minutes
about why it's important to
save, and how the bank is there
to help them save, but
didn't get offered that special
savings account that
had special rules to it.
And that's done exactly to
try to understand where
to draw that line.
So if it's a situation where
you're particularly concerned,
then you could actually think
about having treatments
designed specifically to test
whether there is a direct
effect without the treatment
you really care about.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm kind of jumping
onto the last point as well.
But the one encouragement design
that I'm familiar with
is one where a subsidy was
actually utilized, but then it
was a random distribution of who
was offered the subsidy.
And, for that matter, because
they're trying to determine a
demand curve, the
subsidy varied.
So maybe you'd be offered
35% off, maybe you'd
be offered 75% off.
Still random in who was given
the offer, but then they had
the encouragement to take
off based on how
big the subsidy was.
But it seem my initial-- not
knowing enough about the
details of the program--
is that there would be a problem
based on the economic
status of those who were offered
a program in the first
thing if they were not
very, very similar.
If I am marginally wealthy and
I'm offered a 35% discount,
I'm more likely to take out than
someone who is broke and
is offered a 35% discount.
Then that would affect
your sample.
PROFESSOR: With one twist.
So it's not the levels that
matter, but it's actually the
slope that would
have to matter.
It has to be not that the
wealthy is more likely to take
up with any given level.
It's that they have to be more
elastic or less elastic than
the poor in order for
that to be an issue.
And then you're absolutely
right, that is an issue.
And then what you're studying
is when you do that subsidy,
you're studying your treatment
effect on those people who are
going to be more responsive
to that subsidy.
Is there another hand?
No.
Wendy, now we're to your
question, multiple treatments.
So let me just say
one more thing on
encouragement designs.
So one of the key things to
remember with encouragement
designs is that in a lot of
situations, the encouragement
design is--
in some situations, it is set
up where the control group
does get into a program.
So where you're dealing with a
10% take up rate in control,
and a 30% take up rate in the
treatment, In a lot of the
setting, though, it's really
more that you just have
incomplete take up in the
treatment group, that
participation is voluntary.
And so by encouragement, all we
really mean here is that a
treatment is being offered
to people.
They can say yes or no, and
they're not being offered to
the control group.
And so we end up with take
up of some percent in the
treatment group, and
zero in control.
Like the savings experiment
that I just referred to a
moment ago, we had a 28% take up
in the treatment group, we
can't make people open
a savings account.
All we can do is offer it to
them, and we had a 0% take up
rate in the control.
We did a similar thing in the
same place in the Philippines
on a commitment account
to stop smoking.
Again, 11% take up rate in
the treatment group.
We can't make people want to
stop smoking and sign accounts
and contracts to do this.
But we can prevent the
control group.
So there was perfect control in
the control, in the sense
that they were not offered the
opportunity to open the account.
But the treatment group
has to be voluntary.
That is what it is.
And so it's an encouragement
design, with 11% percent take
up rate in the treatment
and 0% in the control.
So sometimes you do have control
on one half but not
the other for who uses.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And so just the main
point is that what constraint
are you going around by an
encouragement design?
Just an ethical problem
if you can't afford
treatment to everybody?
PROFESSOR: In that situation,
I don't know that I'd pose
that as an ethical issue.
But the point to be made is
just that you can't force
people into a program.
It's a voluntary participation,
and that's OK.
So one of the things that I've
often read or heard is when
someone says, well,
wait a second.
This is voluntary
participation, so how can you--
doesn't that introduce
selection bias?
And the answer is no, because
what we're going to do when we
do the analysis of that, is
we're going to compare
everybody who was offered the
account, everybody who was not
offered the account.
And so there's no selection
bias there.
There would be a selection
bias if what we did is we
analyzed everybody who took up
in the treatment group, and
compared them to everybody
in control.
And that would be a
flawed analysis.
But that's not what we do.
So if you ever hear someone say,
ah, encouragement design,
doesn't that introduce a
selection bias, because
participation is voluntary?
The answer is no.
That only introduces selection
bias if you do
the analysis wrong.
What you want to do is compare
what's refereed to as the
intent to treat analysis, and
it means comparing everybody
who's offered to everybody
who's not offered.
Multiple treatments.
So this goes back to
Wendy's question.
This is one of the areas where
I tend to think is most ripe
for helping--
going back to one of the first
points I was making about
making sure that the evaluation
speaks nicely and
informatively to needs of the
implementers, needs of the
organization.
That a lot of times, there's
very specific operational
questions that they have.
Should we really
do it this way?
Or should we do it this way?
I really made some tough choices
here, and I just went
with what I thought was best.
But gosh, if the research can
actually help guide me and
tell me whether this particular
component is
necessary or not, that
would be great.
So imagine you're doing--
let's go with Wendy's example
of an agricultural program.
And suppose that you're trying
to decide, how important is
this training component?
I'm going to provide seeds,
and introduce people to
marketplaces.
I'm just making something up.
Let's not get into the details
too much, but let's just say
there's a training component
alongside of it.
And that training component is
really expensive, it takes a
lot of time.
And I'm thinking to myself, OK,
I can help twice as many
people and drop the training, or
keep it my current program
size and have training.
What's better?
Well, the research can help
answer that question by having
an evaluation which evaluates
the overall program, but then
also randomizes whether or not
there's training involved.
And so this is one of those key
areas where it's a win win
for operations.
Where you can help answer
questions for them beyond the
simple impact question.
There are situations in multiple
treatments that we've
been in where there's
no pure control.
And there's nothing invalid
about doing that.
It does validate the study, but
we just have to remember
that you're no longer saying,
what is the impact of the
program compared to not
doing the program?
You're now comparing it one
option relative to another
option relative to
another option.
And hopefully in the design
there, you have one option
which is kind of like a placebo,
so that you have some
group that you really don't--
it was in a very extensive way,
but you have some method
of being able to say what
the overall effect is.
But there's many situations
we're in where that's actually
just not part of what
the study's about.
So we've done savings product
designs are a perfect example
of this, where we're dealing
with people who opened a
savings account.
There's no control group of
people who were not offered a
savings account.
We're just dealing with a bank
and they take people in.
And the question to us was,
well, how can you help our
existing savings people
save more?
So we tested something out in
three different countries
where we sent people
reminders to save.
So half the people basically
got a little text message
saying, hey, don't forget
to save this month,
and half did not.
So we have no control group
here of people who got no
savings account.
So we're not measuring the
impact of savings on things.
We're just measuring the
impact of getting this
reminder on how much you save.
And we've done similar things
with loan repayments.
There's no study on the impact
of the credit, we're just
testing out operational
questions about how to run the
program better.
And in those types of designs,
we'll often test out five
different messages all
at the same time.
I think I said that slide.
Oh, maybe not.
Yeah, we talked about
randomization in the bubble.
So this is the list of
the various things
that we've now described.
And just remember that these
are not mutually exclusive.
Multiple treatments and
encouragement design in
particular kind of fit within
almost any of these other
things going on here.
Any questions so far?
OK, part two, gathering
support.
So here are some things
that we commonly hear.
So this part of the lecture is
really all about how we deal
with this kind of introductory
conversations, exploratory
conversations where we're trying
to work with partners
to figure out how to go about
doing a randomized trial.
So one answer which is always
a tough one to get, but I
already know the answer.
And I don't want to risk
learning that we
do not have an impact.
There are situations that we'll
be in-- and I don't mean
to sound like a pessimist-- but
there are situations we'll
be in where you just realize
this is not a
good setting for it.
You have to work with
people who actually
want to know the answer.
And you can recognize that
merely observing that their
program has grown is not
necessarily a sufficient
measure to say whether they've
had an impact.
And it's certainly not a
sufficient measure to say
whether their program is a good
allocation of resources
compared to other programs that
have also had similar
operational success.
And so when we have to make
the tough choices, this is
where we need the evidence.
Listening is probably the
single most trite but
important thing I have to say on
how to have these types of
conversations.
Trying to understand the
perspectives and the
objectives of the people
in the table.
What is it that's making
them tick?
What is it that's making them
have this conversation in the
first place?
And finding ways to make the
research operationally useful
is perhaps the single most
useful and important thing to
do when working in the field.
One thing that I've often found
too is that often in
practice, there's a caution.
There's almost a mistrust that
some might have if they're not
familiar with what is
that's going on.
And it's one of the most
important things that the
field staff can do in working
with the organization is to
just gain the trust of the
people in the field who are
working for that organization.
And some of this comes about in
getting their feedback and
input into things like
survey design.
Having it so they feel part of
the process, and their input
is received and incorporated
into what we're doing.
And that's good for the
program, good for the
evaluation to get
their feedback.
It's also good in a purely
interpersonal way, in terms of
helping to have a relationship
that's good by making sure
that people feel that they
are part of that process.
So some other specific
things that come up.
The first, one of the most
common things is gossip.
People will talk.
So what do we do if the control
group finds out about
the program?
So I think the thing to think
about is to try to separate
out these types of issues.
Let's just put this into a more
general category called
spillovers.
So spillovers meaning there's
any sort of indirect effects
that are going to occur, from
those who were treated to
those who are untreated.
I think it's really important
to separate these into two
categories.
There's natural spillovers, and
let's call them research
spillovers.
Now, by a natural spillover,
what do I mean here?
I mean a spillover that is
naturally occurring.
That is, if you go and you
provide a service to 100
people, the fact is this is
going to affect those 100
people and 200 more.
And that's the nature
of the intervention.
It has nothing to do
with the research.
The example that you have
a case on is deworming.
We're going to deworm
half of you.
The other half will benefit
from that, because you're
going to be less likely
to catch the worms
from the first half.
Let's say I took half of you
right now, and I went into the
other room, and I gave you a
whole big lesson in power
calculations, and I ignored the
other half, and I didn't
give that to you.
Well, there'd be a spillover.
You'd come back, you're in
a group, you'd talk.
Oh no, no, I just learned about
power calculations, let
me show you.
Hopefully it'd be
a positive one.
So these are all natural
spillovers though.
There's learning that
takes place.
You teach some people,
they teach others.
You deworm schoolchildren, other
schoolchildren benefit
because they're less likely
to catch the worms.
There could be negative
spillovers.
We go and we offered really,
really cheap credit to some
people, or we only offer it
to some because we're
constrained.
That's the organization.
That's just how many
loans we make.
It gives them a competitive
advantage--
I'm not saying this is right.
But this is an argument that
people will make when they are
arguing against subsidized
microcredit.
And what does this do to the
people who don't get access to
the microcredit loans?
It shuts them out of business.
It makes it so they can't
operate their enterprise
because they're competing
against someone who's getting
subsidized credit.
So that has a negative
spillover.
These are natural, though.
So a good study is one that
helps to measure these things.
And there are ways that we can
design experiments to measure
those types of spillovers.
So a very simple example of
one that measures this is
suppose we have villages.
And what we're going to do is
take 90 villages, and instead
of just dividing them up
treatment, control, what we're
going to do is we're going to
divide them into three piles.
We're going to divide
them first into two,
treatment and control.
So we'll have 60 of those
villages being treatment and
30 being control.
And then within the 60 that
are treatment, we're only
going to go and deliver services
to half the people in
those villages.
So what do we have?
We have a treatment village
that's half treated, half
untreated, and we have
control villages.
Now throw away the people
that got treated.
Just ignore them.
What's an interesting analysis
to do here is to compare the
untreated children or people,
or whatever the intervention
is in the treatment
villages, and
compare them to the control.
These are two people that
didn't get services.
Neither one got treated.
But some of them live near
people who got treated and
some of them do not.
So that measures the
indirect effect.
That measures the natural
spillover.
So if a natural spillover is
something that one was
concerned with, this is exactly
the way you would
think ahead of time about
setting up the research design
to measure that.
But then there's unnatural
spillover, what I was
referring to as research
spillovers.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just a
quick question.
Does the fact that now the
treatment is half the size
compared to the entire control
group, does it matter?
PROFESSOR: Yes, it matters.
And that's a question of
power calculations.
And so you have to trade off
your measurement of the
spillover versus your
measurement
of the direct effect.
But that's a mathematical
problem that can be solved
analytically.
So research spillovers, those
are the bad ones.
These are the ones we don't
like, because it's not
interesting, it's not useful.
It's not representative of what
happens in the real world
when you do an intervention.
It's just an artifact of
the research process.
The simplest example is the
control group person who says,
I don't like the fact that I
am in the control group.
Maybe they don't believe it was
truly random, or they just
don't like the fact that they
didn't win the lottery.
And so they actually change
their behavior
now because of this.
Let's use a very simple example
of being in a bank,
and let's say you're doing
a lottery across existing
borrowers, and half of them
got an extra service to go
along with their loan,
and others did not.
The ones who didn't
get the extra
service, they're now upset.
I didn't get the extra service,
I'm not happy.
Why did they get it?
I didn't get it.
And you can explain, well,
it was random.
They don't accept that that.
And now what do they do?
Maybe they don't pay
back their loan.
Maybe they leave the
program altogether
because they're mad.
Now in studies we've had, I can
honestly tell you we've
not had this happen yet in a
microcredit setting, but
there's certainly things
that we will do to try
to avoid the problem.
So for instance, one of the
studies we had where this was
a bigger concern than others was
we were testing out group
versus individual liability.
Now most borrowers really like
the idea of individual
liability if they're
given a choice.
They don't want to be on the
hook with other people in
their community, they much
prefer to have a loan that's
just to them and them alone.
So when we were randomizing
whether people got offered
group or individual
liability--
and it was existing borrowers
who were already borrowing
from a bank--
what we had to do is take
villages that were really
right next to each other
and put them together.
Because we couldn't have it
that we had these little
sister villages where there
was lots of interaction
across, and one got switched
and the other did not.
So we put them together and
treated them like one.
And so basically, it's another
way of saying this is when you
think this is an issue, you
just need to think about
making sure that you have some
sort of boundaries separating
out your treatment and
your control areas.
Now in an urban setting, it
could be a little bit harder
if you don't have clearly
defined boundaries.
But it's still feasible to
do this type of process.
You just have to think a little
bit about how to do the
boundary, and also what to do
if you have control group
people who do come in.
And so this is an area where
encouragement designs might
actually be a useful way of
dealing with it, is to allow
some control group people in,
for instance, if they come in.
But otherwise not unless they
actually come on their own.
So this is another way of saying
take an urban area, and
you just encourage some blocks
to borrow and not others.
Encourage some blocks to go to
school and get some extra
service, and not others,
whatever the program is.
And that's a way of trying to
make sure that if the groups
talk to each other, it's OK.
It's not going to ruin the
study, and there's no
jealousy, it's just a matter
of some receiving
encouragement and others not.
So fairness, hopefully this is--
the one point, if I had
to leave you with one simple
thought of this lecture, it's
the fairness point.
It's perhaps the single most
commonly raised issue, and
it's the easiest of the issues
to explain in 99.9% of the
settings we're in.
And it's this fairness issue of,
oh, but gosh, I don't want
to do it by lottery, I want to
do it by some other process.
And the answer--
or gosh, I can't imagine
restricting access to people.
And the answer is always just
about the same, which is how
many people can you deliver
in this program?
What's your budget?
Now let's divide by the
cost per person.
And so you can do this for
1,000 people, or 2,000,
10,000, whatever your constraint
is, you have a
constraint.
Now all we're going to do is
use that constraint to then
find a way to do this
randomization, and that's it.
So we're not restricting
access to anyone.
The only sense in which we're
restricting access is perhaps
a bigger picture or thought,
which is if half a million
dollars is being spent on the
evaluation, that's half a
million dollars that's not
being spent on services.
That's the only sense in which
the randomization is costly in
terms of delivering services.
But this is a different
calculation all together.
This is now asking the question
of whether it's worth
half a million dollars to
find out the impact of
this program or not.
And that's just a very
different question.
It's not about the resources
and the fairness to those
individuals, it's about the
question of whether this
program will be done enough
times in the future, and will
the marginal value in terms of
our knowledge about what's
being learned from this study
be high enough to warrant
spending the money on
the research period.
It's a different question.
So on ethics, some of the things
that we'll often hear
are statements like, well, it's
wrong to use people as
guinea pigs.
Or if it works, then it's wrong
not to treat everyone.
So the first thing to think
about is that first
of all, it's not--
I think it's a very leading
question first of all.
One thing to often
ask yourself--
or ask people in this type
of conversation--
is why is this different than
prescription drugs?
Why should we be more willing
to proceed and deliver
interventions and deliver
services to people without
knowing their impact then we
are to prescribe drugs?
We ourselves, for instance,
would never take a
prescription drug if it hadn't
gone through a randomized
trial, or more than one.
And so why should we be using
a different set of standards
in terms of the ethics of the
two, in terms of the bar, the
rigor that we want to use in
order to decide how to
allocate our resources.
The second thing to think
about in terms of, if it
works, then it's wrong not to
treat everyone, I think
there's an important point to
note, that there's lots of
ideas that--
there's two issues that often
come up in this setting.
First of all, there's lots of
ideas that sound good, but
then when evaluated, turn
out to not work.
And even when something works,
the question is how
well does it work?
We have other ideas that work.
So even if something is good,
even if everyone around the
table is totally confident that
it's going to work in
some respect, we don't know how
well it's going to work.
And when we're allocating
resources, we're not just
trying to beat zero, although
that's always good.
We're actually trying to
do the best we can.
And so we're choosing across
five ideas, and
they all sound good.
No one's throwing out ideas
that-- well, I shouldn't say
that, that's probably
not true.
We can probably think of some
that don't sound good.
But for the most part, we like
to think that we're sitting
around the table thinking across
choices that sound
good, and we have to choose.
And so that's the most important
thing to remember in
that type of conversation.
Cost.
So there is two things that
often come up when people talk
about cost.
And there is a common perception
and argument that
randomized trials are much
more expensive than other
approaches.
So I think there's two things to
think about when this type
of conversation or
point is made.
The first is thinking about
what the cost--
it's about doing a cost
benefit analysis.
So let's assume for a
second randomized
trials are more expensive.
And I'll point out some
examples in a
moment where it's not.
But let's say it is in
a given setting.
Well, that's only part
of the equation.
You have to say, well, what's
the cost and the benefit?
The whole point of doing
randomized trial is to think
about costs and benefits too.
There's no reason why we should
think any differently
when we think about
how to evaluate.
So what's the benefit we're
going to get them from doing a
randomized trial versus a
non-randonized trial, and
what's the cost difference?
And if the benefit that we're
going to get in terms of the
reliability in results is high
enough to then make more
impact on our ability to make
future decisions, well then,
it's probably worth spending a
little bit more money on the
evaluation itself.
Now obviously, that's relative
to our existing
knowledge in the space.
If something's already been
tested 15, 20 times, then this
might become a situation in
which you would argue that no,
the benefits don't outweigh
it, because the marginal
impact from the research on one
more study is not going to
be that high.
And so the costs are
not worth it.
I'm not aware of situations
I would say fit that, but
hopefully we will be
there someday.
The second is that the cost of
doing randomized trials is
often not actually more
expensive than
non-randomized methods.
But it's really key to state
clearly what the
counter-factual is here.
What's the alternative method
one's describing?
So it's clearly cheaper
than doing nothing.
And there are situations that
I've been in where my best
advice is don't evaluate.
For whatever reason,
the setting is--
you're not going to get a
reliable result, and the best
thing one can do is to not
do the evaluation.
Let's compare now to the most
common comparison one makes,
which is to a non-experimental
quantitative method.
So suppose the alternative
approach is to survey a bunch
of people who received a
service, and to survey a bunch
of people who didn't
receive a service.
It wasn't done randomly.
It was some people chose
to be borrowers from
a microcredit program.
For those of you who know me
know I do a lot of work in
microcredit, this is why I keep
using microcredit examples.
So I'm going to survey a whole
bunch of people in microcredit
that are part of a program.
And then I'm going to go into
the same community so I can
find people who seem very
similar, have the same
macroeconomic conditions, but
are not participating in the
program and going
to survey them.
I'm going to follow everybody
before and after.
So this is actually a more
expensive study.
Why?
Well, I need a larger
sample size here.
I need a larger sample size
because I actually have to
really understand something
deeper now about who's opting
in and who's not.
And I have to try to use my
econometric tools to correct
for selection biases.
And this costs me sample size.
And so this study would actually
cost more money,
because I would want a larger
number of observations in the
analysis in order to try
to get it right.
Now it's clearly going
to be more expensive.
Now let's flip to another one.
If our counter-factual approach
is to not even do any
surveys, like there's no big
econometrics, but instead to
do a simple before after.
I'm just going to compare
before after.
So you've studied yesterday, you
talked about before after,
you went through some of the
issues that you have that you
don't know what else is changing
the environment.
But if that's the comparison
you're going to be using, well
then yeah, this is the more
expensive, because yopu've got
to survey control group
people too.
That's an example where it's
hard to come up with settings
in which there aren't
outside factors--
economic, social, environmental,
health--
that cause changes over time in
outcomes for people, such
that a simple before after
analysis is in anyway
informative at all about the
impact of a program.
Timing, OK.
I'm going to try to
wrap up quickly.
The one thing to say about
timing is it's very common to
have a constraint where the
organization is like, but we
need the answers now.
Randomized trials are no
different than non-randomized
trials that follow people before
after, but they're
certainly going to be a lot
longer than things that simply
look retrospectively at people
that have already received
services and hold focus groups
and discussions to try to
assess impact.
And there's no way
around that.
So this is a question of just
being patient, and working
with organizations that are able
to be patient in order to
have those answers.
I'm just going to run through
this initial slide so you can
have the basic key points of
the overall plan when we're
doing an evaluation.
So the three steps we have
listed here are plan, pilot,
and implement.
I think it is important to note
that there are situations
where we don't actually
do a pilot.
Depending on the circumstances,
the situations
in which we do pilots are
typically when there's a lot
of uncertainty about what the
intervention is in the first
place, and so we're actually
working with the organization
to figure that out.
Or if there's some uncertainty
about the way the process is
going to play out.
Maybe we're uncertain about
the encouragement design.
We're not sure if it's
going to work.
We're not really sure, will this
actually encourage people
to come in and use
a service more so
than they would otherwise?
So we need a pilot to test out
whether that approach will
have an effect or not.
We just need a smaller sample
just to gauge whether we're
dealing with 60% take up rate
in our treatment group as a
result of encouragement and 10
in the control, or are we
dealing with 12 and 10.
What's our range?
So the five steps we've laid
out here is identify the
problem and proposed solution.
So I think one of the things
that should never escape us is
that you don't take a
randomized trial.
You don't start off saying we
have a tool, now what research
questions can we ask?
You go the other way around.
You want to think, well, what's
the research question
we're asking here?
What is the problem that we see
in the market we're in, in
the society we're in?
What's the market failure that
this intervention is trying to
solve or measure or test,
and then what's
the proposed solution?
Think totally abstractly, don't
even get into what the
randomized trial is and how
it will be designed.
Just think first order about
what the market failure is,
and what the logic is behind
the proposed solution.
Second, and this goes back
somewhat when we're talking
about in terms of identifying
the key players.
There's nothing more frustrating
than a really good
project, where you just don't
have the right players on
board participating and
collaborating in a cooperative
way to make the project work.
Identify the key operations
questions to
include in the study.
This goes back to hopefully the
other theme of my lecture
this morning, is about making
the research into win win
opportunities, finding those
operation questions and trying
to build them into the
research as well.
Then design the randomization
strategy, and define the data
collection plan.
Data collection can be done
continuously lots of waves,
one wave at the end.
There's lots of other tools
that we can use in data
collection, both qualitative and
quantitative approaches.
One of the other common
misperceptions that I've heard
is people saying that there's a
spectrum between qualitative
and randomized trials.
That's kind of mixing
apples and oranges.
Qualitative versus quantitative
is about how you
go about measuring things
and what you measure.
A randomized trial is just about
identification of the
effect of an intervention.
It's about random assignments of
treatment and control, but
it has nothing to do with
whether the measurement is
going to be done through
a qualitative or
quantitative process.
And there's a lot of examples
of studies that we have that
use mixed methods and creative
approaches for measuring
things, and there's a lot of
studies we have where it's
very cut and dry, normal
quantitative, how many
potatoes did you eat
type questions.
So pilots vary in
size and rigor.
The pilots and the qualitative
steps that often go into them
are very important for helping
to understand the intervention
and design it, particularly when
we get into designs that
are doing sub-treatments.
A lot of times those come out of
the qualitative process in
the design of a study.
And then for the actual
implementation--
oh, I skipped something.
Identifying the actual target
population is going to be
covered later in the day,
in the second lecture.
And then collecting the
baseline data will be
discussed later on.
When we do it, we usually
do it, but not always.
The actual randomization, there
is various times and
points in which you do it.
This is what we were talking
about in the beginning of the
class, real time randomization
like the credit scoring all at
once, villages known up front,
and you randomize them in or
not to a program.
Then the next phase is
implementation intervention to
the treatment groups, and this
is where internal controls can
be really critical.
There's nothing worse than doing
all of this work, doing
all these surveys, and then not
having the right control
in the field to be working with
the individuals from the
organizations that are
delivering services to make
sure that things happen
the way they're
actually supposed to happen.
And I've had projects go bust,
where we're working with
organizations that thought they
had the right internal
controls in place.
And when we go in to do spot
checks to see, and we go to
some villages to see, are they
getting services or not?
And lo and behold,
they were not.
Or they were when they
shouldn't be.
And we go back and we try
to work with them.
I've had at least one project I
can point to that literally
we just canceled after
a year and a half.
It was very unfortunate, but
this is what happens when
there wasn't the right level of
internal controls in place.
And I learned.
And then measuring
the questions.
One of the most common
questions we get with
measuring is, how long
should we wait?
And there's really no
one answer to this.
There's often a trade
off with operations.
If there is any sort of holding
back of a control
area, then this is going to be
something that has to be
negotiated and discussed
with operations.
In a lot of situations we're in
though, it's not that the
two sides are actually
differing--
I mean, the operations maybe--
but the head of the
organization might have
incentives that are perfectly
aligned with the researchers.
They want to wait long enough
in order to make sure that
they've given their
program a full
chance to have its impact.
And so usually when I am posed
with this question by an
organization, I usually just ask
right back to them, well,
you tell me.
What do you think you need in
order to see the impact of
your program?
If you're telling me a story
about it being a 5, 10 year
program in order to see
everything flourish, well then
that's your answer.
If you're telling me that this
is like an amazing thing that
just transforms people's lives
within six months, well then
we can go in six months
and see that amazing
transformation.
We might also want to see the
two year impacts, but that
would be something that could
happen with the organization,
and they could say, yes, we
think it's transformation in
six months.
And two years is just beyond--
I mean, I don't know what the
word is to say beyond
transferring.
Lastly, analyse and
assess results.
And obviously, there's a lot
more in the class that will be
discussing that.